Kiss Me I'm Irish you insist
[Applause]
well at least you get a a pretty hot
co-star you know yeah she lives smoking
huh oh I thought you meant Sebastian oh
sorry oh this is awkward
yeah I think it's cute too yeah yeah I'm
gay
[Applause]
actually I'm not so you know how you
shave your own head right yeah all right
so have you ever like just like shaved
the whole thing
foreign
they asked me to ask you what yeah
before you come out they're like ask him
if he saves his whole body help me ask
him does he go completely or is it a
little airstrip what does he know
you know I have to admit I was a little
bit nervous about doing this interview
relax guy I like gay men you know
that's great but I I I'm not gay
I don't believe that why Ryan Reynolds
kissed Andrew Garfield really is that
really a question why I know have you
seen Andrew you've seen him and Andrew
Garfield yeah I didn't even know I was
kissing him until I found out when I got
home that night
there should be a map just to get out of
his eye actually I've only had that one
movie come out and no one even told me
it was premiering it must have slipped
my mom's mind wait what was the movie My
sex tape
thank you who would you say is the best
looking the best looking oh really did I
say that yeah
sorry sorry
so much
hi oh my God
sorry we just killed that camera
there you go that was great
Escape people everywhere if you're not
gay you're
you're a weirdo what if one of your
children grew up to be not gay would you
still love that child
no you would not
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
I don't want you to be uncomfortable I
like to slouch well I'll have a slouch
yeah okay just what's going on here
what's going on here that's my
what's why are you fight why are you
facing that towards me
I'm facing it towards you because you
subconsciously asked me to face yeah
you're sure no you're the king
and who's in charge
all right let's start again all right
let's start again all right let's start
again hi Ricky foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
for every new thing you teach us you
open the world to us like a stubborn
coconut you have always been a huge Ally
for the lgbtq plus Community why do you
connect to that community
I think that I just
I just don't I
some fans kind of sensed a
um some Chemistry Between Your
characters potentially there's a
romantic past was that intended or was
that something that the viewers
and we're so sexual as as a beings you
know and why is that we go to that voice
I don't know because that's sexy not at
all oh okay it's not sexy apparently no
don't find me that see not with no
Debbie's been inside for a long time and
inside jail inside not inside me you
just said I didn't even go there you
probably I'm down to that level oh